[Musique]
on a juste quelques gouttes ça veut dire
qu'ils ont déjà coupé l'eau voilà il y a
plus d'eau
et déjà vu les enfants ont besoin
d'aller aux toilettes régulièrement et
en fait c'est là où c'est compliqué
parce que on doit pouvoir se passer
chasser pardon
et dans une famille de cinq personnes
c'est compliqué là on nous dit qu'on va
probablement passer aussi à quatre tours
d'eau hebdomadaires donc ça en fait je
l'imaginais même pas je sais même pas
comment je vais faire avec mes enfants
[Musique]
les coupures d'eau en eux-mêmes on est
en elle-même induisent des dégradations
du réseau et comme nous sommes en
coupure d'eau depuis 2020 et donc le
réseau se dégrade et donc actuellement
il est estimé à autour de 30% de partes
de perte d'eau c'est à dire que le
rendement serait autour de 70 pour cent
[Musique]